long before there was a DC film universe
Warner Brothers executives dreamed of a
Justice League movie in fact plans to
bring the original Superfriends together
for a live-action outing in theaters
have been in various stages of
development for more than a decade and
the project has taken far more than its
share of twists and turns along the way
from a derailed production to
problematic facial hair here's the
untold story of Justice League summon
the league George Miller who's best
known as the mastermind behind the Mad
Max franchise actually plan to film a
Justice League movie back in 2007 when
it would have beaten Marvel's Avengers
to theaters by several years and
potentially leveled the MCU dominated
Hollywood playing field unfortunately
the project called Justice League mortal
was beset by a slew of problems
including a writer's strike and an
ongoing battle over where to film the
movie in the end the studio pulled the
plug in the film and went back to the
drawing board opting to launch their DC
Cinematic Universe with 2013's Man of
Steel instead almost a flick for a brief
window of time Ben Affleck was a
frontrunner to direct the Justice League
movie and we can only imagine how
drastically different the movie might
have been if he had a flex award-winning
films like Gone Baby Gone the town and
Argo proved that he's got the ability to
write direct and star in movies that get
raves from critics and audiences alike
and given the bumpy road the DC extended
universe is faced with critics thus far
it isn't hard to understand why the idea
of a Justice League movie with some of
Affleck's trademark seriousness and grit
might be appealing but the rumors turned
out not to be true
that was only the start of the movie's
directorial difficulties enter Joss
Whedon after Man of Steel and dawn of
Justice Zack Snyder was supposed to
direct Justice League as well but when a
personal tragedy forced him to step away
from the project one friend was ready to
step in and save the day
Avengers director Joss Whedon with a
little convincing from his buddy Zack
Whedon took the reins and saddled up to
handle his third massive superhero
ensemble flick within the past five
years and he didn't take the job lightly
Whedon went to town making so many
changes that he earned himself a
writer's credit for contributing more
than 33% of the screenplay over budget
with great rewrites come great
responsibility and a bigger budget
between the studio notes in Whedon's
retooled script Justice League
super-sized budget required an extra 25
million dollar
for reshoots not to mention an extra two
months on the set for all the actors
involved it just goes to show that
Warner Brothers wanted the movie to be
the best it could or at least better
than the last one
the million dollar mustache of all the
time and money spent on reshoots a
significant percentage went into
digitally erasing Henry cavils mustache
cavil was already at work on a new film
by the time the studio needed their
Superman back and although producers
managed to finagle a blockbuster
time-sharing deal the actor had to keep
his magnificent cookie duster in tact
for his role on the next Mission
Impossible flick which left it up to
DC's digital Wizards to remove it in
post-production funny on purpose if he
didn't love the dark tone of DC's
previous movies take heart Justice
League is reportedly amping up the
comedy after Batman vs Superman took a
critical pounding for being too serious
Zack Snyder put it because of what fans
have said and how the movie was received
by some we have put the screws to what
we thought the tone would be evidence of
the change was already visible in the
Justice League trailers which suggests
that this is one superhero movie it's
not afraid to poke fun at itself what
are your superpowers again rich april
fools
after the release of dawn of justice
warner brothers started gearing up for
pre-production on Justice League
in April 2016 only to have director Zack
Snyder abruptly exit the film entirely
after throwing an epic public temper
tantrum the twist it was all in April
Fool's Day a gag I'll be at one that's
less funny in hindsight since Snyder
actually did depart the film a year
later after the tragic death of his
daughter there could be only one when
Warner Brothers initially unveiled its
massive slate of DC movies there were
two Justice League projects on the
docket one slated for 2017 with a sequel
to come two years later but after a
tumultuous year for the DC extended
universe the studio changed its approach
to take things one film at a time will
we still end up getting a Justice League
sequel probably but it'll happen the
old-fashioned way with an announcement
issued after the studio counts its cash
the end of batfleck although he's denied
it repeatedly rumors continue to swirl
that Ben Affleck is planning to hang up
his bat suit it's not hard to see why
you might want out of the DC Universe
his first outing as Batman took a
critical drubbing
Justice League had a lot of hiccups on
its way to the theaters and the solo
Batman movie that he was originally
supposed to write star in and direct
still doesn't have a release date
the books well Affleck pull off a Batman
style disappearing act in real life
creeping into the shadows never to be
seen again by the execs at WB oh wow
they just they really just vanish
oh that's rude for now he claims he's
happy to play the Caped Crusader we'll
see how long that lasts
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]